[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are celebrating 300
episodes of
your biscuits that's the name of the
podcast we already said that and we're
going to be doing that
by hearing
hearing
from you
yes we have done we have just embraced
you are now on the line modern
technology
it's not gonna be live it's not that
modern actually uh thank you to all of
you who recorded essentially voicemails
uh filling in the blanks completing
sentences we had a few prompts that
we're gonna that we went through that we
sent out there into the ether and you
responded many of you responded yeah
with lots of heartfelt funny
even some weird things that you said and
uh we're gonna be covering
more than a handful yeah i mean i
had a lot of fun getting a little a
little taste of some of these and um
selecting some of them uh if you're a
long time listener this will give you an
opportunity to see how much you remember
and if you agree or disagree with what
was the most impactful or the most
memorable moments or that type of stuff
if you are
new to ear biscuits are you you know
there's no shame in not having to listen
to everything i mean
just a little bit i certainly don't
it's like
i don't think i was here for most of all
of it yeah
but if you weren't this is an
opportunity to say hey i might have to
go back and find where they were talking
about this or whatever this what year
was episode one i remember we were in
the uh yeah we were in the other studio
we bought this table
i mean uh i mean we were in the other
studio doing that podcast for
more than a year and we we've been in
this studio for at least five
six
of course the ear biscuit started off as
us interviewing other youtubers and
getting their story that's not what the
podcast is now and i'm glad it is what
it is man it's evolved so much i don't
we're not gonna get into that we're
basically talking about
the current iteration of
your biscuits and um
how that's impacted well really that's
what you're looking for that's what you
talked about that's true because we left
it open we left it open and
um
no one in as far as i understood
like recognized or brought up anything
there's one early days well there's one
like intermediate episode which uh
which which we'll talk about but you
know i'll give credit to stevie
she was instrumental in encouraging us
to start a podcast i remember back when
we were trying to figure out what we
were going to call it we were getting
the rug we were getting the
the table
and you know what that turned out to be
a great decision
so
so much of our
professional development
has
this has been such a catalyst for that
in terms of
what what our brand means how we talk to
ourselves ourselves and how we talk to
each other that's pretty much what it is
and how that was the other option for
our audience welcome to when we talk to
ourselves
um you know it's it's
it's
this show has had such an impact on our
lives and our our friendship and um
i'm very grateful for it and i
in some ways
three hundred doesn't seem like a lot
when it's once a week when you've done
two thousand episodes of good mythical
morning but that's not a reason not to
celebrate because it is a lot and damn
it we are going to celebrate this is
this is this is special and i think as
we go through some of your responses
maybe uh
you know that's going to give us some
stuff to talk about about what the
podcast has meant for us as it has meant
things for you but before we get into
that first one yeah i'm very excited
about
september because you know what around
here in ear biscuits land it's not
called september it's called sex timber
he said sex tim that's right starting
next week and continuing through the
month of september
we're going to be doing
nothing but talking about sex on ear
biscuits for a full freaking month i'm
talking four episodes in a row
um the and i'll go ahead and say it the
last episode the fourth one
we will be
taking your questions which we will be
asking you to to submit to us
over the course of uh starting now if
there's any question you want us to
answer any topic you want us to discuss
in the world of sex
sex timber
yeah so i think maybe for the full month
uh you know i don't know
this is not i mean
this this
podcast is yeah you know it doesn't get
too
it doesn't get too damn bad
that's about as bad that's about as bad
as it gets i was just illustrating how
we might curse every once in a while but
let me just tell you cursing and sex
have really nothing to do with each
other well well it depends on if you
come from an evangelical background or
not but which we will get into
but what i'm getting at cursing during
sex let's talk about that we're not
gonna be i mean we're going to be
talking openly we're going to be talking
openly about sex
and so if that's not something that you
if you don't want your strength
your children to be educated by us
and we're not going to do this to
educate you just they make they may just
get you know a sideways education i
guarantee you
everybody's gonna get education on us
uh yeah so sex timber mark your
calendars it's pretty much just you know
once a week one of the problems
september
one of the prompts that we put out is
um
the re uh shoot what is it
ear biscuits is the reason i blank
so let's just start there with a few
let's listen to one
beer biscuits is the reason that i get
in my car in the morning and actually
want to go to work i have over an hour
commute and being able to listen to
rhett link talk about stories through
their lives and be introspective on
different things that have been going on
around the world is really fantastic to
go into every single day starting my
morning with two best friends is
definitely how i'd like to start my day
for the rest of my life
thank you for that noah that was noah
cook are we saying last names uh in that
case i just did some people submitted
first and last name some people just did
first name some people did like
nicknames so we'll just do whatever you
did thanks noah i i mean
i've i think that i would like to ride
into work with two best friends who just
wouldn't shut up in the back seat the
whole time but this is the thing this is
my issue with what noah said is it makes
me feel like we're not giving noah
enough content i mean noah's riding yeah
well he has an hour commute riding to
work
on a assuming
he works daily
you know monday through friday we're
doing this once a week
yeah i don't know what i have to go to
five times a week i don't know what he
does the other four mornings out of the
week but um
taylor does something different let's
listen to that voicemail
hey rhett and link your biscuits is the
reason i get so much stuff done around
my house that is my chicken in the
background if you heard him
but ear biscuits helps me keep focused
on what i'm doing and it's entertaining
as well so anytime that i finish an
episode i realize that i've done about
an hour's worth of work without even
realizing it
so keep it up and we love you
and you guys are awesome
bye guys
and by we
i think
the chicken is included yeah
thank you taylor and thank you taylor's
chicken chicken i would love for loving
chicken in the background
i wish i could be on more phone calls
with people who have chickens in the
background i mean it's just something
that we need more of but i do think that
that is something you know that's how
that's how i listen to podcasts i listen
to podcasts while driving yeah or while
doing something
i mean
do does anyone just sit down and be like
what are you doing well right now what
i'm doing is only listening to a podcast
um have you ever done this i actually
yeah i'm always doing something else
usually driving but i've started
mountain biking i think i told you this
uh i'll mountain bike
up when i'm doing the climbs like
typically my routes are majority climb
and the majority downhill
some routes are a little bit of a little
bit of
both but like especially for the long
climb routes i'll listen to a podcast on
the way up
and then on the way down i'll switch to
music
because you want to listen to the
podcast when you're working hard you
want to listen to music when you're just
riding the gravity
well yeah it's kind of it's it's fun you
know that the music gives me that that
energy to like just
it's it's more fun but it's also more
technical you could die if you're not
really concentrating on
you know missing certain things at a
higher speed because some people feel
like you might need music for motivation
while going up
a hill but i like getting getting in the
zone of of ideas
when i'm just trying to granny granny
crank it up you know well i just gotta
say i i think
i i'm glad that we can be a part of
your lives in this way even if we're in
the background with your chicken
or in the background as you're as you're
driving to work
we're not asking to be front and center
we're not asking to be completely
focused on we want you to focus on what
you need to focus on we just want to be
present it's cool to be a companion yeah
yeah to be along for the ride i really
like picturing what what people are
doing oh they're getting done
right i mean maybe maybe there's people
who just sit down and give it their
complete
you know
i mean for the for the video version and
there are people who who prefer to watch
it on youtube uh
it's still a background thing but i
think you know you'll stop and be like
whoa whoa what's that look on his face
is that an additional meaning is that
another layer there's a layer of context
sometimes yeah faces let's hear from
abby
air biscuits is the reason why i feel
like i should install a window in my
shower
i love you guys i love the pod the
channel's awesome
it's just really nice to see a couple of
best friends succeeding in life
um just by being themselves
pretty epic
congrats on 300 episodes can't wait for
more
happy hat sounds like that's a nice
voice it's a it's soothing it's like a
delilah voice you know what i'm saying
like uh i would like to hear i would
like to hear free falling from tom petty
because i'm thinking about
you know
my eighth grade girlfriend even with the
laugh the little
i mean that was good yeah abby you need
to go into radio
or you at least need to because this is
not a dying industry maybe you should
start a podcast just start a podcast you
got a great voice
two friends succeeding at life by just
being themselves i mean
i
i like that it might be a better again
the slogans just keep coming yeah and
that's uh succeeded i like i like the
mantra of succeed at life just by being
yourself
and i do think that's something that
it you know
we're processing our lives
in front of these microphones
and
there is a level of we've gotten to a
point where there's a there's a level of
expectation that that we can come into
this place is kind of like a safe space
for us to process
and i look forward to that there's
plenty of times when i'm like i don't
know exactly how i feel about this
but i'm going to get it out
and it's it's great to have a venue like
that i mean
that it's kind of it's therapeutic in
that way but it's also so encouraging to
see how many people how it resonates
where
you know
you're having an honest conversation
and
um sometimes i even forget people are
listening
at least maybe maybe
90 percent i'm totally just in a
conversation at certain points
90 huh i think there are times only 10
thinking about the fact that there is
there's someone listening yeah that's a
dangerous place for me and does that
make you nervous well i actually i'm
surprised based on
you pretty much kept yourself in check
most of the time but i it's it's one
thing to give people what they want or
something that's going to get clicks or
get listens
but
it's another thing to just do something
we want to do and for it to work
and resonate well and i would say
this whole idea of being yourself
um
it is
you know making the decision long ago
for a number of reasons to just talk to
each other
one of them just being it was easier
yeah
started us on this trajectory where
you got to keep digging like you know
it's we're not this isn't performance
mode and this isn't you know unlike
something like ron's tap which is
obviously just the scripted podcast
you're putting you're putting your work
out there you're putting your art out
there
this is really putting ourselves out out
there and it's actually
um
given us
like we've revealed more and more and
more about ourselves and actually kind
of began to mor to understand by
revealing and being vulnerable actually
learn more about ourselves in the
process it i mean again
was never the intention it's just
something that sort of happened it's a
win-win
who else do we have chinese
ear biscuits is the reason why
i graduated with uni degree this year it
helped me conquer my travel anxiety by
keeping me entertained and calm on my
long trips in and out of uni thank you
so much
shanice is saying that the reason why
they got through college or uni whatever
that is
the same thing uh in australia i think
is air biscuits i mean
being being able to help it's like okay
this is the this is the show that
shanice goes to
when it's when it's like i'm traveling
i'm
i'm anxious well i always wanted to be
he feels good a uni professor
you know i mean i i i always love the
idea of just walking around a campus and
watching the the leaves fall then going
into a classroom with with like a wild
haircut and beard and like saying
something that makes the students
confused
uh so this is as close as we're ever
gonna get and shanice has basically just
validated that that dream of mine i
don't think that's what shanice was
doing okay right that's right but it is
validating oh i'll take it
do we get do we get like an honorary
copy of the degree
um
i think we might be we might get an
honorary degree at uh that said uni
whichever uni that is uh we got some
more good ones but first let's promote
some merch what are you wearing well um
you know
over in the mythical kitchen
they have perfected this particular
technique of
the palm hill strike yes which i believe
is for garlic they use for garlic but i
think it can i think it transfers to
many different things in the kitchen
but just in case uh you need to be
inspired in your own kitchen
and remind yourself that you are you too
are capable of a palm hill strike get
the t-shirt from mythical.com i love
that it's very action oriented
it's cool i had not seen that until i
just looked at it
that's beautiful you this is the first
time you're seeing it yeah i've been
wearing it for a while since the
beginning of this podcast yeah right i
mean yeah i didn't look down there
almost 20 minutes did not look down
there okay i'm not offended you want to
keep going
yeah well you were
reaching for the laptop so i was
assuming that's what was happening i got
three in a row who
are in a similar
vein still with the prompt
ear biscuits is the reason i blank
here's rosie
air biscuits is the reason i still
understood
i also stopped believing god after being
raised in a very religious environment
and family and the only difference
between me and you was that i had to go
through it all alone
and
hearing you guys story and how similar
it is to mine even though i live across
the globe
just really helped me feel like
i'm
not alone out there
thank you
thank you rosie yeah thanks rosie you
wanna just play you wanna move through
all three of these and then we can kind
of talk about them together yeah here's
matthew
ear biscuits is the reason i'm much more
open about losing my religion and
replacing it with openness and kindness
and curiosity
after growing up in the south and giving
so much of myself to the southern
baptist church my childhood best friend
and i began touring the country and
processing all of that um just out on
the road uh both of your stories run
really parallel to ours and it's been a
joy to share such an eye-opening
experience together through ear biscuits
uh i love you guys thank you all so much
love you too matthew thank you matthew
some we got some
parallelization happening there that's
like
him and his best friend touring doing
something touring band some sort of tour
comedy show situation happening i don't
know i don't know all right i got a
third one here this is amna
air biscuits is the reason i have so
much knowledge about the south in the
united states despite me being totally
removed from it as a pakistani
but you know this place i call home is
also a conservative place with its
islamic traditions rituals etc
i find myself drawing these intricate
parallels inside my head
the patriarchy the underlying racism
intolerance
it's just been a fascinating exercise to
get this outside view of something that
sounds so similar
wow thank you for that that i mean it's
super cool i mean there's so
so much feedback we got at the time and
even now with this prompt on our uh
spiritual journey episodes our
lost years
sub-series deconstruction stories
but it was just nice to see that you
know there's
uh people who are saying they feel
understood and not alone they're
they relate to our situation directly or
they're coming from a totally different
place on the planet well i think the
cool thing about what amna
shared is
this
the talking talking about the patterns
right and you know it doesn't matter
where you're from and it doesn't have to
be the american south or
pakistan but there are so many there are
systems there are oppressive systems
and people who have been in power who
have been oppressing people
forever right
and you know they might come in
different forms but so a lot of people
have suffered under those systems and
then at some point
questioned those systems and questioned
how it relates to them personally and
that's another pattern that's a pattern
that's happening
in the united states and all around the
world i mean we're most familiar with
what's happening in the united states
in the evangelical church and that is
people are leaving in the in the i know
it might seem
like things are getting more and more
polarized and it might seem like certain
very loud voices on the fringes are
getting louder and louder and so it
might seem like
certain groups are growing
but the
the reality is is that in a lot of ways
people are leaving behind those those
old oppressive systems and they're kind
of collapsing on themselves
and i'm sure they'll be replaced with
other things and we're never you know
it's like
we're not immediately going to just have
some utopia but
it's been amazing to see
the number of people who have
just by
us together kind of processing our story
and people hearing like oh this is this
is so common right i don't i don't think
that we were responsible for
uh a movement by any means i think that
we were just representative of a
movement that has been happening for
years and we just vocalized what was
happening in our little corner of this
movement and that was people beginning
to question these foundational things
that they had built their lives on and
now they're seeing more and more people
are in the exact same boat
so you know and this is just a sampling
of similar messages that we got from
people
who are like hey i basically have gone
through something very similar to what
you guys went through and thanks for for
talking about it to rosie's point about
loneliness you know i'm just continually
grateful that we have had the the
benefit of
supporting each other and being there
for each other
throughout
our entire lives yeah and especially
when exploring things as
weighty as
your deeply held beliefs and
practices
you know it's
it's just really encouraging to hear
that us sharing how we
leaned on each other
is
is then becoming something that they can
lean on
and i just didn't know that was gonna
happen
but it's it's cool for people not to
feel alone it's it's such a
you know it's
that's just one of the things if if i
need to cry i can i can think about
either being
lonely or thinking of people being
lonely like that's that's going to do it
i don't i don't want to cry right now so
let's uh let's let's move on to mercedes
actually i think this might make me want
to cry a little bit more
ear biscuits is the reason i was
initially able to get through the loss
of my lifelong best friend
she'd showed me gmm years prior and when
she passed away at a young age from
cancer
listening to their episode about the
loss of a loved one
on a loop each night is what brought me
comfort and company in a time of
isolation and they don't know that they
held my hand through that but i can't
thank them enough either way
wow well we do now mercedes thanks for
sharing that
yeah you know
it's really remarkable how much that
episode
about ben
yes connected with people
uh
and again it's it
whether you're talking about the
deconstruction series you're talking
about the episode where we we talked
about you know losing ben
um
our our intention every time we we get
ready to talk about something
is not like okay well this is really
gonna
this is gonna bring in the listeners
this is you know what i'm saying it's
like
it's really
a decision to kind of look inside
and
be vulnerable and kind of speak from our
perspective which we recognize as a very
particular limited
perspective but what you just find
repeatedly is that
somebody is going to connect with some
aspect of it
uh in a way that we just we're just
sitting here talking about the guy we
grew up with who were sad
that he's gone
uh and then you just see
how many people
watch that and listen i mean on youtube
especially we just they were like oh the
ben episode it's broken four million
views right and it's just it's just this
phenomenon
of just making a decision kind of
unintentionally just to
speak from the heart and sometimes i'm
like well i think people watch that
video because it's the it's it's the
rawest we've ever been
it was a difficult episode to get you
know so nice it was so raw it's like it
is are people watching for the spectacle
of it and okay whatever if some are but
it is really nice to hear that that is
not the
that is not the majority i believe of
why people are watching that episode
it's a legitimate connection and i do
think you know
i it
the experience that we have in being
vulnerable and then seeing how
people
they take it how they will but if
if it enriches their life
that's that's there's a reward cycle
there that then says okay
are there things that i am willing to
explore
i'm more willing to explore things
because i see that people benefit from
it i i think there's a couple things and
one is just personal growth and the
other one is
uh how it affects the programming of the
show from a from a personal standpoint
it and it's not just true of being a
host of a podcast i think this is true
of life is that when you take a risk to
be vulnerable and and
and someone benefits from it
like there's there's a connection
there's there's intimacy there's
it's
there's
help or solace
it's it it fuels that it it gives you
more courage to do that again and i
think that is the development of
uh a big aspect of this show from a
programming standpoint you talk about
something like sex timber
yes
there is a we know that that's
sensational if that we're going to we're
going to talk about sex and so it's not
just
i want to i really want i really want us
to process
sex and talk about it and figure it out
cry about sex yeah
it's not
i mean you're gonna cry during there is
a programming motivation that like now
we're willing to go into unmined
areas of our lives
um
because
it that's what this show has become
and so it there is a programming
producerial decision in
okay if we talk about sex i i think that
people are going to come out of the
woodwork and be introduced to ear
biscuits and i'm excited about that
but i'm gonna do it subject to
the values that we put in place that
we're when we when we do it
we're gonna approach it with honesty and
we're not you know it's not
we're not
just trying to cash in it's not we're
not gonna that we don't want to do
anything to make it cheap
even though conceptually
it could it could go that way i think
we're putting in boundaries where that's
just
i mean
you know as a listener that that
you expect us not to not to like
uh cash in is not the right word but you
know what i'm saying yeah well there's a
yeah it's the it's the use a topic it's
the used vulnerability
we try to avoid what i might call
vulnerability porn
right which i do think is something that
exists in media and exists on the
internet and it definitely exists in our
industry
uh and it can be a tough line to walk
especially our brand is not like our
brand is comedy first with almost
everything we do this podcast has become
a place where we are most honest and
most vulnerable
but when you start seeing people respond
to the vulnerability then the
vulnerability becomes a
a
a content strategy i think it's what
you're getting at yeah and that can feel
a little icky
and so i ultimately what we're trying to
do is hey we're not
we understand that these subjects and us
being
honest about these things may connect
with more people and that may be good
for the bottom line of the podcast and
of the business
but
at no point are we moving into this
place where
oh let's manipulate our audience through
us being vulnerable and that's and
that's something that you got to think
about something you got to keep in check
yeah
and so do you
[Laughter]
yeah right
it goes both ways but we can i mean
with the next prompt
it kind of went in the more comedy
response direction which kind of
balances out what this show's about so i
think we can go there next the prompt is
uh
what moments live rent-free in your head
from ear biscuits and let's start with
alexander
congratulations on 300 episodes guys
have listened to every single one and
the one ear biscuit moment that just
truly lives rent free in my mind
is when the battleship guy was narrating
you guys eating imaginary s'mores
i think of it all the time
and just
a big ol hunger chocolate
congratulations guys keep doing what you
do
there was our buddy dave dave d'andrea
uh voice over artist extraordinaire one
of the last guests we had on the show
where we went through that period where
occasionally we were bringing someone
that we wanted to talk to
uh but that wasn't necessarily famous
it was just more of subject matter based
stuff
and as a voiceover artist
i mean we didn't know we were gonna
start asking them to like
to spit ball
and start doing impromptu vo's for us
but i just remember how much fun we had
and it's cool to know that like
it's cool to create stuff that people
are just going about their everyday
lives and
they just remem
they just stuff is just triggered well
he was he was the voice of battleship
yeah when did we play or listen to was
it was that on gmn i feel like it was a
good mythical more
thing and we were like making a big deal
about the voice and then we tracked him
down yeah
yeah it turns out he was much more than
just the voice of a battleship yeah he
was the voice of us eating s'mores right
which i which i
i do not remember
i could not i didn't remember the actual
s'more thing stuff that we forget
people you know it gets stuck in
people's brains yeah and they're not
even charging us for it how about nia
hello hello ear biscuiteers the ear
biscuits moment that lives in my head
rent free is link's discussion about
sorting mail
because it will be like that sometimes
you gotta go through the laborious task
of sorting through all the junk mail to
reach that one niche envelope that
really gets you going
but it just ends up being a five dollar
rebate check
hey it's better than nothing
i'm really trying to follow this analogy
so in that analogy of sorting the mail
yeah i think i also have to go into
sextober are the different pieces of
mail
different things that you could do with
one partner uh
are they
multiple partners i mean i'm not i'm not
not trying to make any assumptions i i
took it that it was like
different different practices that then
oh you've you found the
you found the right one you found that
right
and so you thought that you were getting
something special the analogy is fun yes
but it can be stretched you know
i
yeah i mean
we've gone from me like speaking in code
and trying to come up with but i mean
that is something that christy and i
would do
and it is something that we can talk
about in sextober it's like how do you
talk about sex in your own house
with other people around children or
otherwise or um
but yeah we've gone from like speaking
in code
and that being like a shocking oh this
is what they're talking about now to us
doing it for four weeks in a row but i
also think that we've we've potentially
ruined actually sorting the mail
like literally sorting the mail for many
people like you just i love it you want
again well you want to go to your
mailbox you want to see if you've got
you know if there's any checks in the
mail and you want to get coupons and now
and now all you can do is think about
link in his bedroom so i on his behalf i
apologize to you if if we have ruined
that for you it all runs together for me
because it's sorting the mail the same
story was when we were locked in the
bedroom
locked in our own bedroom i think it was
i think that's how
i told the story i transfer
whatever it is that we said and did
in an episode
to the internet mind right it leaves my
own mind because it's i did it i was
here it's now it's on the internet it's
available yeah i got more room why does
it need to be in my mind anymore yeah
this is how i think about good mythical
morning when people start asking
questions about
something we ate this i'm just like it
is just a huge blur
not even a very detailed blur let's go
to karina
that your biscuit moment that lives rent
free in my head is rhett talking about
watching
trashy reality tv for seven hours
yeah you were on you were on quite a
tale did i talk about it for seven hours
or did i talk about watching it for
seven hours i don't know everybody in my
memory it was both
you i mean i've definitely watched a lot
of at least at least seven hours worth
of uh trashy reality tv you're giving
people all the time and i i hope you
know let's permission to just love that
crap well
they didn't need my permission nope i
think i got it what i've done
is i've connected
with
the
millions hundreds of millions of people
out there who unabashedly unashamedly
watch
uh
reality television trashy reality
television and i told you this so we're
a big fan of john wilson how to with
john wilson on hbo which probably was a
wreck at some point on this show
and
super innovative documentary series very
quirky very funny very real and raw he
was a guest on conan o'brien's podcast
kona needs a friend
and just somewhere in the middle of the
conversation like conan was asking and
what he enjoy like what kind of
entertainment he enjoys and of course
you got this like
what is the word the auteur you got
somebody like him and you're like well
whatever this guy likes is gonna be this
thing that's refined and he was like
well i'm a big part of bachelor nation
and he goes on to talk about how much he
likes
the bachelor and he then he i mean i
think he talked about he may have talked
about too hot to handle he talked about
trashy reality tv i mean and i explained
why he liked it and i was like you guys
that's exactly why i can start a
commentary channel
well that's been done i mean yeah that's
kind of a big
big fuel for the commentary fire across
youtube anyway
mason or mesa
if that's the french pronunciation
the ear biscuits moment that lives in my
head rent free is the time that link was
telling a story about him and rhett were
in the car on the way somewhere and the
guy next to them at the stoplight got
out of his car to get something out of
the trunk and link was like i have a
great idea i'm gonna play a little prank
on this random man i'm gonna get into
the driver's seat of his car
and rhett responded like it was a little
zany but to me it was insane but maybe
rhett is just used to this i peed my
pants
did you actually do it or did you say
you were going to do it
again
i don't remember the specifics i don't
think i actually got in the driver's
seat but i think i told the story i need
to stand by i think i would remember if
you actually went through with it i
remember you reacting as if it was a bit
zany
just a little bit zany you know nothing
too serious
[Laughter]
uh amy weighed in
the ear biscuits moment that lives in my
head rent free has got to be when the
lighting fell down
the crew quickly rushed in to clean up
rats completely gone off camera and link
is seeing everything is awesome into the
microphone and also trying to explain
what happened
pretty funny
and i think kiko thought he might get
fired
after that it because it was one of
these things right it was one of these
uh yeah
circular spherical
light fixtures i'm just like finally
good content
yeah something happened and i was like
i'm gonna go and
there was a bathroom there was a spill
happening
and um
i mean a number of people responded
about that particular moment it really
lives in people's heads because it was i
guess it was such an outlier to what
normally happens on the show and the
fact that we just kind of went with it
and kept it in there people love that
and that's why i was like yes this is
this is great people are going to
remember this forever but the thing you
have to be careful of is then you can't
engineer
the light falling down next time
you know some people are not you're not
above that whoop the light and see like
that right it would have seemed a little
planned yeah
crystal the ear biscuits moment that
lives in my head rent free
is when red was telling his story about
his family trip to scotland
and then at the very end he says well
turns out we're irish
that moment that was a great moment that
lives in my head that's when i haven't
forgotten that i kind of remember
pretty regularly with a little bit of
shame
yeah but as an earbud i'm ashamed to be
irish i remember it as an ear biscuit
moment because
i knew it was coming but then when you
hit us with it was just like i talk
about burying the lead it was just
perfect
uh that was that just felt good that and
that's one of those things that has you
know recently spending time with my
family the the mclaughlins up in
uh the mountains you know when i was in
north carolina a while back
it was the same group that had gone to
scotland together and so
they're not really letting me live that
down and also kind of holding me to this
idea that we now have to go to ireland
it's a running joke yeah so mom can
break her other ankle who who's who's
pushing that trip the most
and do they because they really someone
really wants to go to ireland uh your
dad my dad definitely mentions it more
than anyone it's hilarious man i mean i
think we gotta make it happen i mean if
we would like to talk about the top 10
funniest moments of the show which i get
you know maybe at 500 episodes okay
that's what we can do
that would definitely be on it like the
think the biggest laughs
from us
anna
the air biscuits moment that lives in my
head rent free
is
it's not that i'm stupid
it's that i can suspend my intelligence
yeah i mean that it was a personal
realization that i had
in conversation with lando and then with
lily i was just trying to i remember
trying to figure out
how they perceived
the internet
me versus the real life dad me
and
i just kind of
i gleaned that piece of wisdom that made
me feel better about i i experienced
freedom
through this phrase even now because
it's like i can be as stupid as i want
and say you know what i don't care if
people think i'm stupid
i'm in control of it right that may not
be completely true but it but that's the
narrative that i'm not now putting out
into the world i think that's a good
story to tell yourself and it could also
be a good t-shirt i don't know i never
we never made it
phoebe
the biscuits moment that lives in my
head rent free is one christmas when you
guys were talking about christmas gifts
that you were getting for everybody and
where i was talking about how he was
getting one for christy he was getting
some sort of like some sort of food like
pickled food or something and he had to
jump over a fence
to go to the place and he completely
like ripped his leg up and it's stories
like that that get me through school
that it was then and now university now
so cheers guys
well phoebe i'm glad i could provide
that
i could help you get through your day by
ruining my leg
i actually how's that going by the way i
went to uh pick up
some food
at a pizza place
that was at that same intersection and i
haven't been to that intersection
since the incident uh-huh
and this is just a couple weeks ago
and i was like oh what is familiar about
this i was like oh yes there's that
place that i got those pickled stuff
pickles things for christy and then
there's the fence
and it just looks so harmless like from
my car
it just looked like how could how could
how could that injure a man
she really did it i don't even remember
what part of my leg it cut but it was
bad
but i'm glad it gave it gave phoebe some
entertainment all right now let's move
on to the
third and final prompt we have which was
ear biscuits changed the way i look at
blank
you ready to get into this yeah
with catalina
your biscuits has changed the way that i
look at therapy
i now think that there's not one person
on this earth who wouldn't benefit from
therapy and i have your biscuits to
thank for that
oh well we definitely agree with you
that's cool
yeah i think you know
coming from two guys who
at one point
definitely believed that
oh we don't need therapy like why would
why would we need therapy
might be counseling
yeah you always make the distinction
between therapy and counseling i never
really went down that rabbit hole so
hard but
you know i was resistant for a really
long time until my wife made the
appointment as i've told before
but i completely agree with you that
this this idea that the stigma around
therapy
is in my mind it's as dumb as there
being a stigma around having a you know
a primary care physician that's worrying
about you physically
um and it's been so cool this is one of
the most rewarding things that has come
out of your biscuits for me just because
i understand personally how
beneficial therapy has been
and people saying that i actually
started going to therapy
because there seemed to be this barrier
that was broken down because you guys
talked about it
knowing how transformational that can be
because it's been transformational for
me
i mean if nothing else came from
anything that we did and it was just
some people like catalina decided to go
to therapy then i think this whole
exercise would be more than worth it you
know what i think i agree with that and
in that case maybe we should just end
every episode with
and go to therapy
and then that's the
that's the end of every episode no
matter what we're talking about no
matter what the ending point is just
tack it on okay matter of fact kiko when
i just said it and go to therapy
you can put that on the end of the
episode maybe we'll just test it on this
and then you give give kiko a version of
you so we can alternate so that you know
it's an us thing and not a methane and
go to therapy
why did you emphasize go i just wanted
to be a little different i'm i i have my
therapy session tonight okay you going
exactly i i i have a confession to make
here we go as much as we talk
as as impactful as it is in my life i'm
still in this i'm still in this weird
place where like every time i'm like
maybe maybe he won't show up on the on
the zoom call because we do it remotely
now i don't know what it is i'm so
well you're not alone we're not going to
get into this but i'm just going to say
it is
it it has been so rewarding
to
my therapeutic experience in therapy
but i will say that it's still a
constant struggle from week to week in
terms of how i interact with how i
approach it
and being ready for it and thinking that
i would rather just do anything else
every single week listen you're not
alone in that and i as someone who has
benefited greatly from therapy
rarely if ever my wife and i talk about
this all the time
when that appointment comes around am i
like
yes i'm always like man i just rather
watch television you know i always want
to do something else i every single time
i want to do something else and then
when it's over i'm like man this is so
helpful so
i don't know unlike jessie who's like
always thinking about when the next
therapy is
and and it just kind of embraces it i
could learn from that all right here's a
here's a different response
rachel
your biscuits has changed the way that i
look at being from the south i grew up
in a small town in kentucky and after
college i moved away to a bigger city
and i've changed the way that i look at
a lot of things like religion and
some social issues and rhett link have
shown me especially through ear biscuits
that it's okay to still embrace your
southern roots but also to grow and be a
new person and have new ideas
thank you rachel that's that's that's a
cool nuanced response because i know i
know that i am guilty from time to time
like if i get frustrated about something
like
people you know being scared of the
vaccine or not believing
you know in evolution or whatever i go
into my southern accent
and i want to portray that mentality i'm
guilty of that i usually defend it by
saying that i am from the south and
those sentiments tend to be a little bit
more highly concentrated in the south
but
i do i'm glad that rachel picks up on
the fact that we're not ashamed to be
from the south we're not ashamed to be
from north carolina like we are proud to
be from north carolina we're pr we are
who we are we talk the way that we talk
and we think the way that we think and
act the way that we act largely because
of where we come from but at the same
time
we do recognize that a lot of those
things that we that we thought
we're
you know we've kind of we've
we've moved beyond them we've changed
we've grown and that's and also that's
not something to be ashamed of there's
nothing to be ashamed with suddenly
thinking some things and doing some
things
that you would have thought were
unkosher or wrong or whatever when you
were when you were younger so
yeah it like you said this is kind of a
nuanced perspective but i appreciate it
because i don't ever want to communicate
that we're like we don't like the south
and we're ashamed of the south
it's just that there's things that we
thought and believe that we are glad
that we no longer think and believe yeah
i think when we talk about it it's
because we still
consider ourselves southern that's
something that we will always be yeah
it's not something that we're trying to
hide
let's see what kate's got to say
beer biscuits has changed the way i look
at old southern white men
that's it
old southern white yeah so now we're
being more specific
you you added this one into is this a
trap for me uh no old southern and white
i guess i am yeah i mean
yeah but hey but no no i think no maybe
we're we're changing the image of old
southern white men maybe yeah there's
people who don't have old southern white
men in their lives then they're live it
will
be we'll be those guys if you need us
too i think
we'll be the old southern guys
oh my gosh i'm just hoping that hey kate
you bought some butter beans yeah kate
is is this a positive thing it didn't
necessarily sound positive
but kate you need to work on your
inflection of positivity if kate went
through the trouble of doing this i have
to believe that the intention was that
it is to be taken as a compliment
you know well compliment accepted there
we go
maggie
your biscuits has changed the way i look
at my own spirituality when the
deconstruction videos came out i was too
scared to watch them
i didn't trust myself to listen to your
spiritual journeys and come out of it
the same person
over a year later i finally worked up
the nerve to listen to them and they
changed my life i was a queer
evangelical christian deeply in the
closet and for the first time i felt
like i had the right to take steps back
from the things that had hurt me my
entire life
thank you for that
wow
thank you maggie thanks for sharing
um
yeah the fact that there was a there was
an entire year
i mean
listen
i i totally get get it that you're like
blows me away i don't want to
you know
i recall people
just
you know
friends people that i was in contact
with
uh when we were kind of going through
our
deconstruction many years ago
who would be like i listen i don't
really want i don't want you to talk to
me about this
yeah because
i have this sense that if you were to
talk to me about this
it would make me think things that are
going to
drastically complicate my life because
listen
it is incredibly difficult to extricate
yourself from a belief system
because usually it's there's there's
family tied into it
there's there's a there's a story and a
security that's tied into it sometimes
there's a career tied into it right
and there's so many things that make it
difficult to be like yeah okay i don't
know if i necessarily believe this but
the alternative
is what the alternative is me going
through hell in order to get out of this
and if you're still in that belief
system maybe thinking that you would
actually literally go to hell if you
were to extricate yourself from this
that's tough that's heavy [ __ ] man
but you know you ca i think you can hear
it you can hear it in maggie's voice
that
they're happy that
they went through this process you know
and i'm not saying it was easy i don't
know maggie's particular story
um prioritizing your own safety and your
own well-being
is
such an important and at times extremely
difficult thing to do in ways that i
can't even begin to imagine yeah and i
just
i'm honored that
again us just processing our experience
has a positive impact in in people's
lives
i'm actually surprised that i don't i
don't carry that around as a weight
there's something about
this experience for me that is
exciting and freeing because
it's i don't have to have all the
answers and i don't have to be
prescriptive for anyone
but
as we've talked about before
sorry to beat a dead horse but the
the cycle of reward of being vulnerable
and just
being honest and then letting people
take it for what it's what it's worth
and taking
gleaning
positive impact in their own life is it
just makes me feel so good
uh
that
i'm i'm somehow bypassing getting in my
own head about it i guess it's never too
late but i'm i'm grateful that are you
are this is a healthy place for me are
you are you are you getting at the
the dynamic of
making the decision to talk about some
of the things that we talk about and
especially when you get into talking
about
religion and obviously doing it from a
non-expert standpoint yeah we may have
been professional christians but
not you know i don't have a a divinity
degree we're not you know
it so talking about these things
just from a personal perspective and
then knowing that it's going to have
repercussions i mean some some of the
i listened to a few of these that i
actually didn't
include
just because it gets not because it gets
a little heavy but you just there's a
lot of people who are like listen i i
basically left this beliefsum i left
this belief system i left this belief
system because you guys decided to share
and that fee are you saying that that
feels like a responsibility that you're
kind of potentially
having a a a weight too too heavy of an
influence on people's like the
weightiest decisions that they can make
i think i could feel that but i don't
because of how
because the boundary that i put in place
in how i approach these conversations
that it's it's not our people's
application is not our responsibility
it's it's it's
the listener's responsibility
what they're gonna apply and how it how
they're gonna how it's gonna affect
their lives just because you
it's not just hearing something
it's
there's a lot of other factors and it's
it's their responsibility how what they
do with it um i think that's how i i
think that's how i
not rationalize it but i think that's
how
i i think the for me the reality is that
we're just a drop in the bucket we may
be the straw that breaks the camel's
back in some situations but just like we
used to say back when we were sharing
the gospel with people on average people
need to hear the gospel 19 times before
they make a decision
you know us telling our story isn't
going to take somebody from
point a to point b there's all kinds of
things that are happening and sometimes
it can just be a slight
different perspective and again we don't
tell these stories so that people will
stop being christians like that's not
the motivation
i will say that my motivation is that
people will remove themselves from
harmful belief systems whether those
belief systems are harmful to themselves
or to others and in some cases that
might be some forms or some expressions
of things like christianity
but
you know yeah i think that
that was maggie's process and and
maggie's process was
being in a belief system where
their identity their very identity was
being questioned that was something that
we had the privilege of not having to
worry about being who we are and the
demographic that we come from our
identity was anything but questioned in
in that evangelical setting it was all
validated
so our journey is different
but yeah i think that
um it it is a heavy responsibility and
we do take i mean i will say we take it
seriously like yeah we calculate the
things that we say and there are some
times that we might say something and
then we think about it a little bit
later and we say
i think that that could be taken the
wrong way and to say hey kiko let's take
that out you know we don't do this
podcast live because we are
very concerned about being able to
we we know that people listen to it and
are getting something from it and
sometimes applying it to serious parts
of their lives so we we take that
responsibility
i'm not saying we edit it on a regular
basis i'm saying
every once in a while we might say
something and be like that might be
taken the wrong way let's not include
that and it by the way credit to our our
team credit to kiko as well as jenna and
other team members who
uh they serve as a filter for
you know i
they believe the best in us and they
know what we're trying what what we're
trying to do and what we're trying to
communicate and so there there are
it's not infrequent for us to have
conversations about
hey i feel like this might have been
unintentionally triggering or came out
the wrong way
um
and then so maybe we just cut around
this just because it could be
misunderstood
and because we're works in progress
right yeah i i hope i hope
that 10 years we say the wrong things
and we didn't even know it lots of times
i mean sometimes i say things and i
didn't and i never intended it all these
things happen but 10 years from now i
hope that i'm different than i am right
now and then 10 years later i hope i'm
different than i am 10 years from now so
um
i don't really i mean the point being
that
yeah i'm glad you don't take it that you
don't take it
you don't take it too much on yourself
you don't see that responsibility as
something that becomes debilitating and
then you're afraid to talk
about it yeah
and
so but i will since we're talking about
the team here i'll say you know what we
wouldn't the show wouldn't be what it is
kiko without your help jenna thanks for
being here too for all your help in that
and uh we really appreciate it kiko i
can't see your face but i know
there it is
in the glass but
yeah it's uh
you know
kiko's voice is also in this thing so
even though it's not that literally
usually
all right we
we're not done with some good stuff
though tucker
let's see what tucker's gotta say
your biscuits has changed the way i look
at myself
uh whether it's from
the enneagram episode or
the spiritual deconstruction or really
any of them it's just nice to hear from
two guys who have similar thoughts as i
do
and
who understand what it's like to grow up
in the south
and
have different ideas so thanks and
congrats on 300 episodes
thanks tucker i had a dog named tucker
and you have a brother named
cole which is his last name well
maybe it's you really are connected
maybe it's actually your dog and my
brother getting together and like
forming an entity that is now
communicating with us
is that possible
talk about being from the south and
having different ideas
[Laughter]
it's okay to have different ideas
you know
tucker thanks for thanks for listening
jacob
your biscuits has changed the way i look
at my button
okay but jacob is talking about
the button that we discussed extensively
that is the button that you press
not to get as graphic as i'm gonna get
during sextember but there is a button
and it's really just a region of your
taint
[Laughter]
that you can press if you haven't gotten
all your pee outs i i saw a bunch of
people talking about milking the snake
and i'm like oh we're not going back
there but you get you're getting pretty
close yeah right that is part of it
sometimes uh but
the funny thing is is we had a
discussion with a group of guy friends
that listened to the to the podcast
and uh if i recall correctly they were
either split or college buddies they are
just not just guys who listen to the
podcast yeah none of them i didn't want
to specifically call them out but yes
our college buddies i don't think any of
them
knew about the button and i thought they
all did yeah i mean maybe i don't know
if everybody's got a button
i definitely got one
well i've told you what i thought but i
just don't want to go back into it
because if i'm
that's the one that i'm like oh maybe i
shouldn't have talked about that one
well but you know what it apparently had
an impact on jacob all right let's get
to gabiya
yeah biscuits has changed the way i look
at my embarrassing or not so good
moments in life
hey
at least i have a good start done
hey listen at least i have a good start
that's our philosophy i gotta say
doing this podcast has actually changed
the way i think about
difficult stuff there's been a few times
now i may not project that i am
constantly worried about things but i'm
pretty much constantly worried about
things right and so like especially if
i'm on
like a high
overlook well i'm scared of heights but
no like if i'm on vacation and i and
like i mean jenna can attest to this
when i was in
scotland and i don't know i think we we
there was a moment where i probably
talked about this in the in the thing
but where i realized that one of the
fans weren't insured because i thought
that they were automatically insured
because i'd use my credit card which
automatically takes care of that but
because they were beyond a certain
number of passengers that they didn't
apply and so i'm driving these vans
around uninsured and i'm in the middle
of like the highlands of scotland and i
start freaking out and
i'm like calling general like we're
gonna figure out how we gotta do this
and
so anyway
but it had doing this podcast has
changed the way i approach those moments
where i think the world might be about
to end i know that not having uninsured
vans is not like an apocalyptic
situation but sometimes i can quickly
get to that point but when something cr
that day in scotland when all of a
sudden like the bridge
went out and the water was coming across
and i was like i don't know how we're
going to get back and i think my mom's
got a broken ankle and we got to take a
ferry
in those moments i'm holding on to the
comfort of knowing i'm going to be able
to talk about this on your biscuits you
know if i make it i'm going to be able
to bring this to the ear biscuiteers and
we're all going to connect by me talking
about this harrowing experience
and i but you know what you don't have
to have a podcast
to have a good story
and i think that's the that's the lesson
and uh is it you just have to have a
really
robust blog
you don't even have to have a blog you
just having a good story you know and
what was it um i thought you told me
that somebody told a guy back home i
don't know if he made it up but when i
was leaving and moving out he said
remember it's better to have a good
story than a good time
and i don't necessarily know if i
specifically relate to that because i
think being in the moment and having a
good time if you're not having a good
time at least have a good story that's
the right thing that's the saying if
that's what it should be if you're not
having a good time at least have a good
story there you go you know put that on
a t-shirt yeah
those are all the
voicemails that we're going to read i'm
sorry we couldn't play all of them but
that would be crazy
um
and but we listened to every single one
actually we didn't
but we listened to enough of this to a
lot of them yeah and we cherish all of
them thank you for submitting your
voicemails thank you for being a part of
this
it's
it's a privilege it really is an honor
to be to find ourselves in a position
where we're just talking
and then it's a it becomes a part of
people's lives it's
memories are triggered there's inside
jokes are had
uh
relationships are formed
and broken and
over the podcast itself is
shaped so significantly
by the ongoing conversation that we have
with you yeah you know in the
alternative timeline if you know the
multi one particular understanding of
the multiverse theory is correct there
is
one timeline where
rhett and link decided to start ear
biscuits and they talked to each other
and they never read anybody
talking about it and it's just it's the
rhett link with no influence podcast
just going on and on and on do you think
about how different that version of the
podcast would be than this version of
the podcast which happens in the context
of the community of mythical beasts who
listen
it drastically different it probably
wouldn't exist but it probably would be
drastically different so
we've thanked the crew
we've thanked each other i think thank
you thank you thank you um and now we're
thanking you
dear listener for for making us a part
of your of your listening life
or if you watch on youtube you're
watching and listening life
it it means a lot to us to know that
for over an hour every week we're
we're a part of your life it's just
it really is
crazy
to think about it hashtag ear biscuits i
mean tourette's point let's keep the
conversation going i do have a wreck
you know i love a good music documentary
you know and i got an i got a number of
people in my life that are that will
send me stuff
and get me hip to some
some news new music docs because i i
like them but i found this one on my own
well it wasn't hard to find because when
you're if you have apple tv
a new show is going to pop up and this
one
is called uh
watch the sound with mark ronson
mark ronstein of many years ago when we
went to a a
a youtube creator summit like an
invitation only
uh a small group of creators going to
this room in new york and then they
bring in people like wes anderson or the
previous year was will smith they're all
you know um
mark ronson came in there
and
he told a story about developing
his album and getting stevie wonder to
play on his album and the way that he
told that story
i was just i was in tears like i was
crying i just remember how much it moved
me
and
then when i saw that he has a series on
apple tv
i was like i gotta check this out and i
i quickly remembered how he's
he's he's a really good
storyteller and the way he's he's an
interesting personality especially on
screen but you know if you don't know
who mark ronson is he's he's a uh he's a
he's the uptown funk guy with bruno mars
he's a he's a amy winehouse's producer
and he came up that way and
um so now he's a very well established
uh music producer and dj but in every
episode he goes through
an aspect of music production
and even if it sounds kind of dry like
episode one is on auto-tune episode two
is on sampling i haven't watched episode
on reverb synthesizers drum machines
and
distortion but based on the first two i
love it because it it's really immersive
he talks to really high profile guests
like he he interviews paul mccartney and
that interview is woven throughout at
least the first two episodes
the one on autotune he kind of goes
through his own personal journey of
of
going from hating autotune
to
trying his hand at it and it talk about
vulnerability there's this hilarious
moment where he's like
trying to sing
through an auto-tune filter having never
really done it and it's like a little
cringy
and for a guy who like has a reputation
it was just it's just really refreshing
how he approaches this thing so if you
have any interest in the things i'm
talking about you'll love this
watch the sound
mark ronson
well thanks for sticking with us on this
journey of 300 episodes and you know
what we're going to be back again
next week with number 301 and also the
beginning of september
and go to therapy
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]